the bombs have fallen the highly
radioactive dust has mostly settled and
the survivors of the human race have
fled underground in a bid to survive
deep into the bowels of the Moscow
subway the Metro series drops players
into this nightmarish post-apocalyptic
feature with the first two games in the
series Metro 2033 and last light
delivering a terror filled
claustrophobic journey through tunnels
and stations teeming with horrifying
abominations plus their mittens and with
the third installment in the series
Metro Exodus due for release on February
15th main character Artem will once
again be reaching for his trusty collage
only this time departing the Metro on an
epic trans-siberian journey across
Russia but before you venture out into
this vast post-apocalyptic landscape you
need to be prepared in this 3 episode
miniseries we're gonna both look back at
what we need to know from the previous
games in the series and gaze ahead at
what's new in Metro Exodus think of this
as you're a faithful gas mask to filter
out any poisonous ignorance lovely
despite the dangers of this
post-apocalyptic future humanity clings
to life in the Stations of the Moscow
Metro the largest of which contains
glimpses of pre-war civilization there's
bars markets and even a bits of theater
who said the apocalypse can't be
fabulous and while the majority of our
teams journey in 2033 and blast light
takes place within the cavernous Warren
of the underground metro tunnels on
occasion need arises for him to set foot
on the treacherous surface the Russian
capital is now but a shell of crumbling
buildings burned-out cars and even the
remains of a plane brought down as the
bombs fell ooh I'd sure hate to know the
terror that these people always
oh good a flashback that's it I'm
nervous to be again Metro Exodus on the
other hand will take players permanently
outside of the Metro as the main
characters undertake a train journey
across this slightly still irradiated
but recovering Russian landscape whereas
the previous games were largely
claustrophobic affairs Exodus will drop
players in a series of sandbox survival
environments huge areas to explore will
each with unique factions ecology and
wildlife there will always be a critical
narrative path though driving the story
forward
but those brave enough to venture off
the track could be rewarded with new
supplies new gum parts or new friends
and speaking of nightmarish monsters
2033 and last light feature a gruesome
cast of tunnel dwelling monstrosities
including the wolf like Watchmen which
hunt in packs giant aggressive River
shrimp which also hunt in packs and
something called the librarian which I
can only assume is some kindly old lady
oh no I assumed wrong so at least this
spiders are small oh good lord killer
with fire
an exodus however now that Artyom and
crew have left the tunnels behind we can
expect to see a whole load of new
mutants creatures whose mutated biology
has not been constrained by a life
underground so far trailers and gameplay
has introduced us to these horrifying
human animal things called humanimal z'
now I'll never remember that we can all
agree that they are terrifying but at
least they're mindless Adi oh god he
just threw a brick there smart run
thankfully not all mutants and Exodus
wish to brick you to death there's a
whole post-apocalyptic ecosystem out
there to discover complete with mutated
wildlife all interacting with one
another the mutants you encounter will
also vary depending on the weather and
time of day thanks to the new dynamic
weather system and day/night cycle so if
you wish you can find an outpost and
rest to change the time of day and then
head outside at midnight into the pitch
dark because you know I have no idea why
you would do that in the next episode
we'll be exploring combat and survival
in the Metro series
what do incoming players need to know
from the previous games and what's new
in Exodus
find out next week
played on the world's most powerful
console
[Music]